bonjour gérard vespière merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin
vladimir poutine qui appelle alexandre
loukachenko a dialogué appel salué par
l'opposante fait la nature à 9 sky a
notamment comment est-ce qu'il faut
interpréter cette déclaration du
président russe dans un contexte
particulier entre sanctions occidentales
qui à domicile escalade verbale sans
nombreux dossiers est ce que c'est un
signe d'apaisement
un bonjour à vous ah oui oui je pense
que c'est une très grande habilité à à
nouveau un de la parade du président
russe parce que premièrement il est
toujours intéressant d'avoir soit en
diplomatie soit d'un point de vue
militaire
l'initiative or hélas l'initiative il à
l'effet de surprise donc voilà il prend
la lumière à c'est positif en terme de
communication deuxièmement à illies ah
la la
le positionnement et tenant de la russie
en tant que médiateur en tant que homme
raisonnable en tant qu appelle au
dialogue ce qui on n'a pas eu l'occasion
a souvent d'entendre ou de voir et
troisièmement il donne un cadre un
résident un biélorusse qui est pas
forcément toujours prévisible elle donc
on a vu le problème des migrants on a vu
le problème de la menace sur le gaz donc
je pense pas que la russie apprécie
beaucoup
l'imprévisibilité du président
biélorusse donc là on lui donne un cadre
un cadre de dialogue et qui convient
tout à fait aux crèmes là parce que cela
va prendre du temps donc à la hausse il
y à un gain le kremlin et assurer une
stabilité en biélorussie pendant
quelques temps et quelle réaction à ce
qu'il faut attendre de minsk
je pense pas que ning c'est beaucoup de
moyens de d'éviter cette orientation
cette suggestion cette demande russe
elle le président loukachenko va devoir
s'y plier entre guillemets donc la
réponse de l'opposition a été tout à
fait prévisible et est simple et
opérationnel oui pourquoi pas mais
encore faut-il qu'il y ait des
conditions remplies pour que ce dialogue
s'installe conditions remplies ça veut
dire bien que nous puissions nous
maintenant qui sommes partis de
biélorussie contre 1 revenir au pays
pour négocier et deuxièmement libérer
les centaines de prisonniers politiques
quelles relations entretiennent ou
vladimir poutine et alexandre lukashenko
vous l'avez évoqué on l'a vu récemment
le kremlin a démenti minsk sur la
fourniture de gaz à l'europe qu'est ce
que ça illustre
écoutez je pense comme je le soulignais
il ya quelques instants il ya un côté
imprévisible du président biélorusse à
n'oublions pas donc il a oscillé entre
l'europe et et moscou n'oublions pas que
il y a eu ses déclarations du quelques
jours avant l'élection présidentielle de
2000 20 comme quoi il y avait des
troupes spéciales russes qui rentrait en
biélorussie il s'est présenté comme le
sauveur de la nation donc je pense que
cela n'a pas fait un très plaisir à aa
au kremlin donc vous avez cité à nouveau
l'histoire des menaces sur le gaz donc
voila ce président
imprévisible et bien maintenant il a une
feuille de route que m'ont dit il à un
cadre d'action il faut qu'ils prennent
du temps pour négocier
vadimir poutine a appelé un récemment à
minsk et bruxelles à la reprise du
dialogue alexandre loukachenko s'est
entretenu avec la chancelière allemande
d'ailleurs angela merkel quelles
conséquences futures
et écoutez je pense d'abord si on
revient un apaisement sur l'ensemble des
dossiers donc et énergétiques politique
migratoire
à cela est un être un plus pour
l'ensemble des parties et pour la
biélorussie a donc en particulier et
puis il y a toujours donc dans cette
dualité du monde diplomatique n'est ce
pas à des négociations avec moscou pour
le rapprochement et puis des
négociations avec bruxelles pour obtenir
aussi levée des sanctions et dialogue
donc la biélorussie a beaucoup de
travail devant
vladimir poutine a dit également hier
que l'europe ne devait pas accusé la
russie de tous les maux il a affirmé
aussi des bombardiers occidentaux ont
approché son pays à une vingtaine de
kilomètres dans le même temps moscou a
procédé à un nouveau tir de missile de
croisière hypersonique sur une cible en
mer blanche comment vont évoluer selon
vous dans les prochains jours les
relations entre la russie et le reste du
monde
je pense qu'on va rester à peu près sur
cette tonalité de gesticulations
militaires il est question de
négociation sur les armements avec les
états unis les questions de négociations
aussi dans le domaine des armements
spatiaux ou de l'activité militaire
spatial donc voilà avant de parler et
bien on fait voir ses muscles c'est une
très vieille recette je pense que
personne n'a de crainte à avoir sur les
actions à un militaire des deux côtés
parce que cela fait partie du jeu avant
des négociations
à l'issue de la réunion des 27 ministres
des affaires étrangères de l'union
européenne à bruxelles le chef de la
diplomatie recettes borel a annoncé
qu'il s'était des sites mis d'accord sur
l'adoption d'un nouveau train de
sanctions à finaliser dans les prochains
jours à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre selon vous exactement
je pense qu' il peut y avoir une attente
dans la mise en place d éventuelles
sanctions puisque maintenant il y a des
gonflements du dossier migratoire et je
pense que bruxelles a très bien réagi en
mettant en avant un nouveau concept en
disant nous allons poursuivre tous ceux
qui instrumentalisent
les êtres humains et donc c'était
destiné à
faire faire machine arrière à tous les
intervenants de la chaîne logistique qui
ont amené les migrants depuis la syrie
où depuis l'irak jusqu'au biélorussie à
gerard julien avait avec ce qui s'est
passé en l'a vu au début du jt les des
migrants qui sont de retour en irak on a
évoqué également l'appel au dialogue de
vladimir poutine
d'alexandre loukachenko avec
l'opposition biélorusse ça veut dire que
avec ce qui se passe avec les signes
d'apaisement l'union européenne ne doit
pas mettre de sanctions maintenant à la
biélorussie ou à la russie je pense
qu'on rentre dans un round d'observation
il y a il ya eu une escalade sévère il
ya une stabilisation il ya un début de
désescalade donc je pense qu'à
invariablement bruxelles va tenir compte
de l'un de l'évolution de la situation
il est difficile de mettre des sanctions
à partir du moment où la nature du
problème tend à disparaître dans un
premier temps attentes et il sera
toujours temps de mettre des sanctions
en place c'est à nouveau il y a des
problèmes si le problème diminue à ce
moment là il faut en tirer les
conclusions logiques
dernière question vous venez d'évoquer
une désescalade qui est amorcée est ce
qu'elle est amorcée avec les mots
prononcés hier par vladimir poutine on
souvient il ya quelques jours le
secrétaire d'état
français aux affaires européennes
clément boon avait dit que la russie a
été très certainement la solution
écoutez je pense que la désescalade
c'est pas forcément dans les mots alors
être contribuer à créer un climat mais
la désescalade est dans l'action donc il
ya une escalade en faisant venir avec
des moyens aériens importants des
milliers de migrants a depuis le
moyen-orient au chaud riant jusqu en
biélorussie eh bien il faut que la
l'ensemble de cette chaîne logistique
asma shine machine arrière et que
d'autres migrants reviennent
progressivement vers leur périple au
d'origine à ce moment là effectivement
il y aura des escalades il pourrait y
avoir un nouveau dialogue merci gérard
espère d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes le fondateur
du webmagazine le monde décrypté